this is Startalk in the film arrival
where they got a linguist and a
theoretical physicist and they no no no
it's not how you play this no no you'll
be a linguist to aliens all right but a
cultural linguist to aliens I'm sorry
nor do you bring the theoretical
physicist I'm sure he's a smart guy but
we got aliens here please so
I would bring a cryptographer who specializes in
decoding messages and I'd bring an
astrobiologist, of course. That's what I
would bring. And so you would first set
up a common vocabulary but you would do
so by referencing things that you know
we would have in common and that would
be science. That would be science.
You might show a lightning spark, you
know, what do you call this? You know they
would have seen it because it's
moving electrons, and they took a ship to
get here. They must know something about
electricity, okay? You don't show them an
apple and say "we call this an apple."
What do you call it? "We don't have apples,
I don't know what the hell you're holding up."
So we would show maybe the periodic table of elements.
The organization of that chart
is surely universal. Literally universal.
right if you like this please remember
everything that we do can be found
commercial-free plus exclusive original
content all on Startalk all access com